big dog big dog coming through i'm
ebonne a shopper NBA champion husband
father lyricist you see me give my fists
off in there and be a son but now I'm
gonna drip director me and my counsel
are gonna upgrade one person staff so
right we'll meet let's go
[Music]
so guys we headed over right now to meet
up with gay brother of Sean Seiler and
we just excited to be able to sit down
with him in a forgive his drip some
direction that's what we're here to do
as the director my trip council includes
people I trust my father Otis my stylist
brick little back story on Game one of
these highly toted athletes out here in
Miami not one that we're gonna put in a
shadow one that's work to worked his way
up
stellar ball player as well as football
player mother said that he loves some
sweats a shirt and some flip-flops
clothes and fashion are usually a first
impression for people when people see
you walk into a room besides walking in
forgetting your name cuz they calling
you handsome I just think it'd be cool
man to give him a couple of looks that
just work for him
I'm Gabriel tillers mom Simone Taylor my
son is about to go to college and I
would like for him to have a little bit
more interest in the way he dresses he
thinks he has some drips but he really
needs a little bit more help but you
should be open to wearing different
styles you should dress more
professional because you know like
you're going out into the world now I've
never seen you wear these either I drop
38 your nose oh no what are you talking
about
oh yes Sophie put these over there put
these under the bed no we're gonna put
them right up under the bed bye-bye I
saw you fear bye-bye shoes you got to
get your trip together
[Music]
Gendron Isaac's has rolling tada
okay what's up G I stopped God pop 100 G
come on bro gonna sing your mama was
telling me that you'll be doing the
Hooper look and the football look too
much yeah you wanna do the sweats as I'm
seeing you don't think we all do it
today we gonna get you courtesy gap you
know sambito report right we're gonna
let you try on some new stuff man and
see if we gonna walk you into college
but like a little dip we're gonna come
check some [ __ ] up
[Music]
so Jay this is Brittany come on hustle
counsel does he know Brittany is my
father oh hey nice name
they got bringing it real impolite you
play basketball and football you want to
hit people what happened that when I
wanted to play football
I really would have been code
no he see him going across that line and
threw a pass and he looking in and
linebacker lay about what you can get up
we gonna get to the next part she gonna
walk you through some of the stuff that
we're gonna look at you know just for
options man yeah gets you right man how
your mom proudly I've always been able
to wear whatever what's crazy is like
that's really I'll learn how to get
dressed I look like I work in a theater
somewhere just like a painter and get
dressed
power ancient of all huh I feel like
they should cute classics man right here
bring them out don't you think pop
that's something I would over high
school as you guys say looking dope my
brother
first fit some simple but that fiery
look denim jacket white tee vintage
khakis slim fit easy for game to put on
and flex in I like what you got going on
Brenda can we get him into his second
look just picking you up though I'm
already dressed what you wearing when we
come out we're going back you're telling
my time um this is that moment that I'm
was you could pick up one girl what you
wear when I pick you up you could bring
one girl I'll know how okay i coul you
out now you play two sports you get one
girl what you wearing out the cream its
lat just slap okay little slack so what
we doing on top but ankle but low shoes
only want high shoes well she looks low
shoes I always do but enough I want to
turn neck keep going crazy turn you look
crazy
I like the top of it and you got a quick
change yes sir by the time that outfit I
will hang with you I would get out of
the car as your driver only to have a
drink of whatever punch that y'all got
it's all screwed in oh yeah show me how
you like he's such an athlete well you
make me proud they're not crazy
hey baby proud Oh ton of Tiffany got no
jacket like this I do yes God your
closet spread all through your closets
all Jets let me let me see these day
they in the closet who Kappa never want
to work
I'm where I'm proud of this time where I
wear them that's my pops man game second
look is effortless with a classic
t-shirt the modern khakis with a slim
fit dress it up with a varsity jacket
you found the flaw not to take away from
the other stuff but they got stuff like
this yeah no nice stuff you know I know
pretty did you know what they got stuff
if we need stuff no like I look like a
different person
you are the man everybody sitting at
home camera will never go out of stuff
last look for game camera cargo pants
got flex easy pullover hoodie utility
jackets are complete just a little extra
trip I've been thinking how I miss my
dog why how is to Lena I thought that we
up all so we filed an anal so let's talk
Sue's if you had to say you got a
favorite what are your favorites well
then glue games what an iconic if I had
a favorite sneaker ever
and you know what's scary about it I've
never worn them and I have a the air bag
I'm probably gonna start wearing them
now that we've had this conversation but
you can grab the Snuffy grab the honey I
ain't no sing
I did it I thought it looked great on
all elephants why the why the Bhangra
15 jacket was my favorite are you like
the GJ and why would you two like the
varsity Bill Carson was great he's gonna
win with whatever pay a shoe combination
that's three looks my boy get to walk
away with one choice and as we weigh-in
gave notice trip is crazy
come on brother rip the wrong way
brother no you gotta go if the green is
is different and it stands out more
tired that she was aware to me now
acceptable but know everything you
weren't not wear to the office if I was
your age but I ain't your age though
good luck my friend
I'm glad we could get you all set going
into your college career and your
college education in a look that doesn't
force you to be an athlete I'm glad it
makes you comfortable and I know you
like this outfit stay right here
you gonna see you out of here with your
stuff man we want to say good luck
[Applause]
I'm game Taylor I appreciate everything
you guys got me true
I got you go rock out
[Music]